close our economic freedom our national
security interest these are the things
that are important to Americans in the
airport it to me because America is
exceptional and we have to get our
economy in order so that we're free not
only here but all the way across the
world
[Music]
next on American history TV Supreme
Court Justice Stephen Breyer discusses
the influence of Foreign Relations on
American national security and civil
liberties he talks about cases featured
in his book the court in the world
American law and the new global
realities including Korematsu versus the
United States and cases involving
Guantanamo Bay detainees the Supreme
Court historical society is the host of
this event it's about an hour honored
today to have as our lecturer Justice
Stephen Breyer whose topic will be the
court in the world American global law
and the new excuse me American law and
the new global realities Justice Breyer
is been a long-standing friend of the
society he has delivered lectures as he
has as he will be today he has hosted
dinners he has introduced speakers and
were very fortunate that he's giving us
this lecture he truly is a man that
needs no introduction and there is not
an introduction I could do that would be
complete in the time allotted but let me
touch on some highlights if I may he
graduated with highest honors from
Stanford he then went as a Marshall
scholar to Magdalen College Oxford where
he received first-class honors with a BA
degree in philosophy politics and
economics he went to Harvard Law School
where he also excelled was articles
editor of the Law Review he done clerked
for justice Arthur Goldberg and like all
clerks he's very circumspect about his
work there but he does acknowledge that
he contributed to the first draft of the
goal Ginsberg excuse me Griswold versus
Connecticut case which for those of you
that are not lawyers is the case that
recognized a right of marital privacy
after clerking for justice Goldberg he
worked in the Antitrust Division of the
Department of Justice he taught at
Harvard both in the law school in the
Kennedy School of Government he was
chief counsel to the Senate Judiciary
Committee from 1978 to 1980 and he was
nominated by President Carter to the
First Circuit nine days after Carter had
lost the 1980 election he had so
impressed senators on both sides of the
for his work on the Judiciary Committee
that he was confirmed 8210 he then
served for 14 years on the first circuit
the last four years as chief judge when
he was nominated to replace justice
Blackmun in 1994 and he assumed the oath
of office in August of 1994 so we're
coming up on the 22nd anniversary so if
you'll all please join me in giving a
welcome to our lecture whom we're very
lucky to have this year thank you
justice
thank you very nice introduction and
this is a formidable group I mean I'm
talking a little bit about history but
you actually know about history and
quite a lot of you I was told by a
historian he said well anyone can make
history sub but it takes a real genius
to write it that's why all right anyway
and books aren't that easy I mean there
there was this one my publisher is
grateful for your introduction but they
I wrote a book once about regulation it
was a little technical found its way
into the hands of a Los Angeles Times
reviewer don't ask me out he decides to
write a review and he says well this is
in the Alice in Wonderland Alice and boy
Dormouse emerged from the pool of Tears
and they've heard this story before and
the Dormouse begins to read from Humes
history of England well why are you
writing that why are you reading that
said Alice were wet and and this is the
driest thing I know now that was before
Breyer wrote this book you see how I
said well no this is not about
regulation this is about the court and
it's terribly important that you support
actually these kinds of things because
it's important that people know
something of the history of the court
and so I'm very glad to be here and I'm
glad to be talking about this and I'm
glad you're here listening very nice of
you and what is this book about
so I say that it is it's the analogy
it's a kind of report a sort of report
from the front about what well in if
you've ever read the Charter House of
palm which is a very good novel it opens
where the hero if I breathed el dango is
on the battlefield at Waterloo and the
bullets are flying by and the horses are
running back and forth Napoleon's
charging this way in that way and del
dango he thinks to himself he says you
know
he says something really important is
happening here today I wish I knew what
it was and that's what this is about
in respect to when I hear words like
globalization or interdependence or
shrinking world that's a good cliche all
true of course but what is it about and
I can't tell you a big answer but I can
do this I can draw on my own experience
over the last 20 years or so and in
terms of that experience it is here in
this Court I've seen a change and the
change is just in the number of cases
where you have to know something about
what's going on abroad in order to
decide the case correctly and
intelligently and I've seen that number
grow I mean I think they were pretty
rare when I first came here now if you
looked it up and said well I think it's
15 or 20 percent I think you'd be closer
you see it's going like that and so what
I've tried to do is say I'll tell you
what it's like here for those who are
interested I'll tell you about these
cases specifically and I will group them
and I'll show you different topics and
under each topic I will give you some
examples and then I'll say and what
would you like me to do about it and how
would you like me to decide the cases
because they call on different skills
and different kinds of knowledge so all
I'm gonna do in the next 20 minutes or
so and then we can have half an hour
maybe and I will have questions after
it's just give you a few examples some
are pretty interesting and I'm summer
medium interest in any case let's go to
a very hot topic which has a long
wind-up short pitch and that is a well
known topic what do we do about civil
liberties in time of national security
and there's much less in the court us
reports than you might think
Jackson said that once Jackson said you
know he said looking to see what the
framers thought about this kind of
the inherent powers of the President or
the powers of Congress and the powers of
that versus civil liberties he said well
he says it's like trying to it's like
Joseph's trying to interpret the dreams
of Pharaoh and you start looking it up
and to discover there isn't a lot
written not in the u.s. reports why not
well I mean for many many years I think
the general view and judge of judges
here as well as judges abroad where when
you have first you have security needs
like a war or real security problem and
you look at the document the document
says this power is primarily the
president's it's Congress it's not the
court ah but what about the Civil
Liberties well they're the courts do
have something to second and sometimes
there's a clash and so why is there so
little I think the answer is Cicero he
was not one of the founders but they did
in fact know about Cicero and that
attitude prevailed for many many years
Cicero said something like I used to
translate it this way I'd say when the
cannons roar the laws fall silent I
thought that was a good translation
until somebody pointed out that the
Romans didn't actually have cannons so
that sort of wrecked that and that then
well in time of war well when the arms
are etcetera you see the point and now
you say did the court live up to that
yes you won't find that many cases
during the 1812 or Abraham Lincoln I
mean he had a real problem obviously but
very few cases one may be no the Supreme
Court in the Civil War
now maybe Lincoln didn't get involved in
civil liberties he didn't
I mean tens of thousands of people were
arrested the the Stewart a Seward who
was a Secretary of State called in the
British ambassador and he said you see
this bell here he said I can push this
Bell and I can have anybody I want in
New York thrown into prison he says I
can push it twice I
can have anybody I want in Indiana
thrown into prison tell me he said this
the Queen of England have such power say
there were a lot of civil liberties
problems and the court got involved
after the war was over that's different
that's justice Jackson he thought that
was a good idea he wasn't there at that
time but later he said let them do what
they want the Army during the war and
then will come in after and said what
they did was wrong that's not I think
for reasons I won't go into it very
workable judicial philosophy but but
nonetheless look and see what happened
to civil liberties in the Civil War we
can understand it but the court doesn't
intervene at all well let's go to World
War one and there are many books written
on this about learn at hand the masses
says you know there's freedom of speech
being interfered with here and he was
alone or nearly alone courts stayed away
from it until after the war or World War
two we know that we know that wasn't my
mother used to take me down I grew up in
San Francisco we drive down the
peninsula and I was a small child go by
Tanforan racetrack she said that's where
they held the Japanese in World War two
and the voice of you know the note of
approval was not in her voice
I mean 70,000 American citizens of
Japanese origin were ordered to report
the Tanforan racetrack Santa Anita if
they lived in Los Angeles and 70,000
American citizens were just moved
why because General de Wit 6th army head
said we better get them out of here the
Japanese might invade and they might be
a fifth column they were citizens they
were told to report they moved them and
Roosevelt signed that order that isn't
what happened to the Germans and
Italians and it isn't what happened to
the Germans and Italians or the Japanese
and in England or other places which
also had problems but it is what
happened to the Japanese here they went
to the camps against their will
well-known story but there was one
person Fred Korematsu who said this is
ridiculous I'm an American citizen and I
think they shouldn't be doing
yes if they want to go look into my
background fine but not send me to some
camp and he found a lawyer now I met
Korematsu once actually very interesting
he was across the street of where we
live up in Cambridge because he was 8
years old at that time very feisty guy I
liked him very much and he was having a
drink with our neighbour and for one
then and for one was the daughter of a
man called Ernie Bezeq Ernie Bezeq we
used to play poker with my father was
the head of the ACLU in San Francisco
and he represented Korematsu in this
famous case the ACLU wouldn't sign the
brief they got into it later they did
get back into it but you see this was
January of 1942 February March April May
that's when the order was signed sending
sending them back that spring of 42 and
that was just after Pearl Harbor and who
was supporting it Earl Warren he later
said it was one of the worst things he's
ever done but he was there supporting it
and who was opposing it J Edgar Hoover
well he said we can take care of it you
know to the camps now Korematsu said
well we're gonna win this and Bezeq
thought that too
and the case finally got to the court in
1944 and in 1944 there was no risk of
invasion there was not a problem with
submarines off the shores of of
California they were pretty certain they
were going to win and before the case
went to the court when it was the brief
was in the Justice Department to lawyers
burly Edison Burling got a hold of this
and they read an article somewhere
written by a commander in the Navy who'd
been involved in intelligence they got
suspicious of this whole story you see
because the government was saying the
Defense Department was saying or the
world war army department there was that
they were saying that but in fact there
have been 763 instances of
intercepted communications messages sent
to submarines offshore there were
several instances of sabotage we said I
think we should look into this and he
called in the FBI who said no there was
no sabotage the sabotage took place
after they'd already been moved and the
FCC came back and said there wasn't one
instance not one instance of messages
being sent out to submarines
what are the 763 whatever was messages
those are all buck privates didn't know
how to work the machines so Burling
antenna said that's pretty interesting
that's amazing sir how'd you do this so
quickly they asked this big pile Oh so
we didn't do it now we did it in 1942
and we showed it to the general he knew
it at the time so they wouldn't sign the
brief they said we're not signing we're
not going to defend it then they had a
big fight between the two departments
and who was brought in to mediate but
Herbert J Wexler some of us remember who
that was and Herbert J Wexler who was
running the war part of the Justice
Department was a master genius and he he
wrote a footnote disowning the the Army
on this issue and he wrote it in words
that no one could understand so he
convinced Dennison Burling to sign the
brief and the Justice Department's
physician I don't know you read it you
see if you can figure out exactly what
it was but in fact who won the case the
government six to three famous case and
who is it who upheld the government
black Douglas frankfurter the Liberals
who had in fact later would sign Brown
versus Board and they were all on the
government side it was the three
dissenters were Roberts Murphy and
Jackson and there was six to three well
I thought for a long time maybe they
just didn't understand that there was so
little evidence
and footnote who reads footnotes Arthur
Goldberg told me that years ago he said
don't write anything in a footnote you
want anybody to read it in any case I
thought maybe they had me then I got the
transcript for the of the oral argument
and charley horse key some of us know
that name he was representing the
japanese-american defense league and he
said to the judges go read the footnote
that footnote denies that there's any
basis to this whatsoever and it did and
it did so they had read it what were
they thinking and my guess my guess is
they were thinking Cicero yes a and I
while it was a guess I later met someone
who actually I hadn't gotten this source
was he got the source of the conference
and he said black walked into this
conference and he said well somebody has
to run this war it's either us or it's
Roosevelt and we can't and so we better
let Roosevelt do it and that was the
argument you read the opinions and you
see if you don't think I think it was
the argument I think that's what did it
by the way the only one who has it a
hundred percent right into it was in
dissent was Murphy he's got every fact
right every fact so this is the problem
of a historian but you're interested in
I figure I'm gonna find out and somebody
must have told him he couldn't know all
this stuff berlin uranus must have
somehow gotten to him so I phoned gene
grassman you know gene grassman was his
law clerk and and really ran everything
dank gene dress was 90 years old he was
alive at that matter hope he still is
but I'm not sure but anyway I called him
and I said now tell me tell me
somebody must have gotten to Murphy how
did Murphy get all those facts right you
know what he said I don't remember
so there we are no that's Korematsu
there we are of Cicero now March on to
the Korean War and you'll have the steel
seizure case very interesting because
the court there during the midst of the
Korean War Jackson and the others say to
President Truman no you cannot seize the
steel mills even though they were told
and Truman was trolled by cabinet
officer after cabinet officer if you do
not seize the mills there will be a
strike no production and people will be
killed in Korea a lot of them as a
result but the court went the other way
so why do I think my own view after
reading a lot of this and going through
the history of it they told Roosevelt he
couldn't do it Roosevelt had gone too
far of course he was dead so it was
easier to tell it and moreover Truman
wasn't nearly as popular as Roosevelt
had been but there we have it whatever
the reasons I mean they had gone too far
and I think the people on that court
thought Korematsu was going too far you
know I thought they thought no there has
to be a stopping place but there isn't
much in the u.s. reports there's some
but there isn't much it shows a stopping
place until you get to steel seizure and
read Jackson's opinion it is absolutely
fascinating it's become well known
because he categorized the different
sources of you know Congress agrees with
the president he can do a lot of things
doesn't agree with them can do hardly
anything at cetera but the real interest
in it to me at this time is his view
about presidential power being exercised
and he's very cautious and he's saying
he says look what happened in Europe
when the president starts when a
president I'm not saying what happened
here but he's his but but but stop now
you come up to more recent cases four
cases out of Guantanamo for all brought
by the detainees every one of them the
detainee not necessarily the most
popular person United's
I mean bin Laden's chauffeur was not and
is not the most popular person in the
United States brought against the
President or the Secretary of Defense
all for the detainee wins Congress has
passed a statute first we had to
interpret the statute then Congress
passed a statute specifically saying
they can't get into court now all we
said it was unconstitutional one of them
says one of the cases says but I'm not
enemy combatant we said you can hold an
enemy combatant if you're in an active
war that's like the Germans or Japanese
soldiers in World War two but if they're
not enemy combatants so some say we're
not we're peaceful farmers I was a
peaceful farmers at one of them and the
government said well why'd you have a
bazooka and he says every peaceful
farmer in Afghanistan does it but you
see there's an argument there and so
we're asked to say what do they have to
do they have to go through the rudiments
of due process at least have impartial
decision-maker etc I have an opportunity
to present proofs and arguments so in
essence we have four detainees who won
but what is the case about what was
Cicero replaced by and if I had to
choose four or five words that would be
Sanger O'Connor's who wrote in one of
the cases that I joined her opinion on
this I think that's the courts attitude
in those cases certainly and probably
will be it says she says the
Constitution does not write a blank
check to the president not even in time
of war great fine the only unfortunate
thing about that is well what kind of
check does it write mm-hmm now you're
beginning to see the problem from our
point of view from the point of view of
the judges the lawyers and others what
kind of check does it write it's not too
hard when you're not in the business but
now we're in the business so if we are
in the business of answering that kind
of question there have to be answers and
now maybe you'll see as well why our
opinions are not particularly popular I
mean there are some groups and say you
never should have gone
in this you shouldn't have gotten into
this you should be back at Cicero I say
really do you want Korematsu you want
the Japanese 70,000 American citizens
then the other side says but you should
have been more more more thorough or not
thorough but more definite you should
have you should have had a few rules
here you should have said whether they
can use hearsay or not use hearsay in
these cases why was it so vague why is
it just so narrow and I see the reason
the true reason so narrow so because we
don't know the answer that's the truth
of it we don't know lots of situations
can arise and now that's the long
wind-up what's the pitch is how are we
going to find out and that's not
something that we alone have to think
about if we're in the business of saying
when it goes too far these efforts by
Congress and the President to narrow
civil liberties in the name of security
if we're in that business we better know
something about what we're talking about
and that I think requires in part
knowing what other countries do and
that's why I said Chilton for her she
took us to it we had an exchange with
the Brits where that we spent two days
trying to figure out what they were
doing a general and they we discussed
all this what what is France do what
does Israel do what do these countries
and why and what works and what doesn't
work and and the lawyers are going to
have to find out because the lawyers are
gonna have to tell us and that requires
the sources of information says they'll
come in and they'll say to the judge
judge there's no good reason for this
there's no reason why are they doing it
well they'll have an answer you know and
somebody's gonna have to figure out
under what circumstances the judge look
at the answer and when do you do it in
camera and when don't you do it in
Cameron then they'll say why not why not
do it this other way it's called the
less restrictive means and that'll be up
there as a question too so it'll be the
lawyers and probably some professors and
the judges doing what they usually do
trying to go into a subject which they
don't know that much about learning
about it and try to come out with
sensible answers and that will involve
knowing what happens
as long as terrorism is not just a
national problem and no one thinks it's
just a national problem so that's what I
say
alone wind up and a short pitch but some
of it is not such a short pitch I mean
try cases involving international
commerce a case I really liked I thought
it was so interesting you explained
quite a lot to me was a student from
Thailand Cornell he discovers that books
same books textbooks same textbook same
language he's on sale in Bangkok for a
lot less money so he writes to his
parents and says send me a few they sent
quite more a lot more than a few he sold
them and and the publisher got a little
annoyed so the publisher brings a case
against him now whether he can or cannot
buy and resell from Thailand there is an
answer and it's in a statute and the
statute has that footnote was nothing
compared to this statute I mean it is
really hard to understand but that isn't
my point my point is I go into my office
and there is a stack of briefs like this
and they are from every place in the
world I mean they're from Asia they are
from Europe and they're not all about
books and I said why are all these
lawyers and countries to filing briefs
in this case I mean it's it's sort of an
interesting case but I mean this many
briefs and and I find the answer down
about here where one of the briefs says
you know copyright today is not just a
matter of books or books films and music
I mean by an automobile it's filled with
software and a lot of the software in
some places is copyrighted or go into a
shop any shop you want and you'll see
Goods and the goods will have labels and
the labels will be copyrighted and will
tell you something your answer to this
case this
from Cornell we think will affect 2.3
trillion dollars worth of Commerce yeah
I mean even today that's a lot of money
that's why they're there I mean
eventually the student won but that
isn't my point my point is this is all
over the place can someone in Australia
can someone in Australia who bought some
shares in an Australian company over an
Australian exchange you say sue under 10
B 5 securities act for a claim that the
Australian company lied about a purchase
it made in Florida of a company well can
they are can't they I mean we have to
decide and we have briefs from the
European Union from Britain from the
Netherlands are we not only have briefs
from the government's we have briefs
some lawyers who say the government
completely wrong it's the opposite and
that's normal and and they're from all
over the place and we came to a
conclusion that they couldn't sue
primarily because it was Justice Scalia
wrote the opinion I joined it primarily
because of the way it would interfere
with their own efforts to enforce their
own anti-fraud law or an antitrust
that's an old question here but but my
goodness it comes up with a force a
vitamin distributor in Ecuador sues a
company in maker of vitamins in Holland
and he sues him in New York now let's
see why did he sue in New York let's
think about that maybe he just the
vitamins were so expensive because of
the cartel you see he was too weak to
get to Europe that's a possibility
there's another possibility called
treble damages anyway he's in New York
and he wants to sue and can he or can't
he and again we have the briefs from the
EU explaining to us that if we allow
this lawsuit they're going to have real
problems with their own antitrust law
that comes up security
it comes up in antitrust it comes up in
intellectual property were the only way
you're going to get a sensible answer
interpreting a statute of ours which
doesn't clearly have the answer is to
know how to interpret so that these laws
begin to work together in harmony to
achieve an objective and the word will
be used as the word comedy which is a
perfect word since no one ever knows
what it means but in this case it is an
effort to try to bring and you can find
case after case where we're trying to
get laws of different countries to work
harmoniously together and that doesn't
divide the treaties treaties were
interpreting treaties all the time
oh well wait let's go back for a second
because I want to save the treaty run
for a second let's think of Dolly
filartiga another good example Dolly
filartiga who is Dolly filartiga she is
from Paraguay she came to New York she
came to New York that she wanted to find
and she did find another man from
Paraguay who had tortured her brother in
Paraguay to death and she also found a
statute passed in the 1790s called the
Alien Tort Statute and it says that a
person an alien can bring a suit in a
court for harm caused by a violation of
the law of nations what was it about
pirates probably at least in part see
because the rule used to be I think in
the 1790s you find a pirate you hang in
and by the way first you hang him upside
down shake all the money out there and
give it to the victims if you possibly
can all right who are today's pirates
the torturers yeah we said maybe torture
is over that's what Henry Vettes what
they said in the Second Circuit and she
won and she went back to Paraguay and
said I came to the United States wanting
to look that torturer in the eye and I
went back was so much more even though
she didn't collect money but you see
vindication and we've had that produce a
whole industry of course and once an
industry of cases and then the question
was well what are the limits and those
are harder than you think to figure out
it's not just who are today's pirates
all complicated
statutes are complicated but there are
some special things about this and one
of the special thing with the law of
nations well what I mean where do we
look now why is that a problem
it's important to understand one reason
why it's a problem or difficult not
overcome a bull but still race is a
special difficulty and that's what
Madison said and I like to keep this
these words in mind when I'm dealing
with something that stems from abroad
and I think it helps explain some of the
opposition to the attitude I'm sort of
taking he said that this constitution is
Constitution unlike Europe he said it's
an it is a document it is not a document
that's given by power to Liberty it's a
document given by Liberty a charter of
power said well I haven't got that quite
right but the idea is the following in
Europe the power is at the center it's
the kingdom and it's still at the center
and that power may produce a charter of
Liberty they may end up at the same
place we do but it's not the same theory
what this says is the residue of power
where the where the power comes from is
the people and this is a document that
if they don't give you the power you
don't have it you say not different now
think of people being taught that for
200 years in this country not always
practicing and I promise but nonetheless
nonetheless and a suddenly it becomes
clearer why there's kind of an emotional
reaction I mean we elect the president
we elect the Congress the judges we
don't elect them but at least they're
appointed by people who who we did elect
at least they're American judges but who
appointed those people in The Hague you
see it you see the attitude you see how
do we trace that back to us now that is
a special problem that we have doesn't
mean they don't have the power but it
does mean that you have to explain it
pretty clearly why and how they got it
or start thinking about what are we
going to do
what about apartheid that's a very good
one is apartheid is apartheid an
equivalent of a pirate
maybe so when people brought cases
against companies based on that theory
and the South African government filed
briefs saying we don't want judges in
the United States getting involved in
this we have our own system it's called
the Truth and Reconciliation Commission
and all that American judges are going
to do is start getting everything mixed
up let us deal with our own problem so
how is it that the American courts will
treat that you would just do whatever
the State Department says do we work out
a system see how we're beginning to see
special problems and in with areas like
this remember there is no Supreme Court
of the world in other countries may have
similar statutes and we better be able
to have a system however we interpret
similar words here that will work out
overall I mean the example to use is we
always read in the paper whether it's
true or not that every single foreign
country seems to want to sue for Henry
Kissinger now poor Henry Kissinger III
mean I don't know why but you can't have
a system where Henry Kissinger is going
to be sued everywhere maybe you could I
do i I'm sure he wouldn't like it but
the problem that I'm trying to
illustrate with that is this somehow it
has to work out so that if other
countries do the same thing you won't
have chaos and there is no Supreme Court
of the world to have a final rule on
such matters and all of those kinds of
difficulties and more are involved in
those ten or fifteen or twenty words in
that Alien Tort Statute and it's
difficult and it's been to this court at
least twice and we've tried to figure
out answers and sometimes we agree
sometimes we don't but that's human
rights a little example of it that's
right there
and why did I say treaties I started out
with treaties because I began to think
of treaties as always being subject
matter
for a court of course but suddenly we
have three cases over two years that
involve a single treaty the subject is
the abduction of children hmm now you
know who knows something about abducting
children in the law they're called
domestic relations judges in the States
I know some of them it's a really hard
job a very difficult job and what one of
them Eddie Ginsburg up in Cambridge told
me he always starts when he has a
fighting couple before him he says I
hope you can work this out because if
you can't work it out I'll tell you I'll
decide it and whatever I decide is gonna
be worse than what you would work out
it's very hard and who knows even less
about it they say federal judges know
nothing about this subject we stay far
away from domestic relations state
matters state J so why in heaven's name
are we starting to interpret a treaty on
on child abduction because it's a treaty
and what won't get into that my goodness
there are there are sort of warring
groups one group is very much against
child abduction I mean nobody's Forry
but I mean they may they are very much
but well before just wait they're saying
this has to be interpreted a certain way
or there'll be too much child abduction
who's on the other side people who feel
just as strongly about abuse of women
because very often the abduction is
motivated by abuse and so they they have
to go to different courts in different
parts of the world making somewhat
similar arguments to a lot of different
courts and asking us we have two cases
like that why are we into this business
why is it in the treaty because marriage
today is more and more a question that
crosses national boundaries nobody's
going to change that it's just going to
get more and by the way there there are
treaties what nobody disagrees with the
proposition that you have to look to
foreign law you should look to foreign
law you must look to what foreign courts
say when in fact you're interpreting a
treaty everyone agrees with that all
nine of us we've said that
and well okay is that something that
comes up often well professor kiss AC
had his students go out and looked and
see if you got an answer to this
question he said how many organizations
are there in the world now let's do that
loosely let's say it created by treaty
or created by executive order or created
by something which have the power to
have a bureaucracy and that bureaucracy
makes rules
maybe ratified but those rules have this
characteristic they bind individuals or
companies from more than one nation so
you can think of the World Trade
Organization or think of parts of the
United Nations I mean now suppose you
wanted to count up how many how many
organizations are sort of organizations
how many you think there are how many
think they're more than a hundred nobody
thinks they're more than a hundred yeah
of course more than more than a thousand
more than 2,000 we still got a few yeah
there are more than 2,000 there are more
than 2000 and we belong to about 8 or
900 of them I mean you know there's the
International bluefin whale Commission I
mean that's one but what about the the
International Olive Oil Council
that's another they're all over the
place and one of them you won't even
think of and I say this particular on
campuses if I'm talking about this
subject because the students will know
in two seconds and they won't have
thought of it I said what is the
organization that affects you every
single day more than any other the the
answer to that question you know what it
is it's actually icon can see puzzled
looks yeah I have a puzzled look as I'm
same age but they know icon is the
organization that deals with domain
names icon is the organization that
regulates the Internet what is icon it's
a company in Los Angeles or sort of a
company it has some kind of status there
and they're making rules that affect
everybody or go to the ball with ball
who meets in ball
all the banks meet Inbal and so do our
regulators and they go to Baal and they
make they don't make agreements exactly
they sit down and discuss problems and
they agree what to do and then the
regulator's come back to their different
countries and they promulgate the rules
giving everybody a chance to comment on
what they've already decided now that
may not be to it that's an overstatement
possibilities
myself into trouble here but nonetheless
that's going on in a lot of places and
gradually these questions are coming up
to the court gradually I'll give you an
example of a big question that's decided
all over Europe and we haven't had it
yet but we've nibbled around the edges
of it I mean King Congress delegate the
authority to do what I mean if we say
they can't delegate any authority I mean
how are we gonna solve the world's
problems I mean not that we'll solve
them but we do make a dent but if you
say they can just delegate to the
International bluefin fin whale
Commission I don't know the Olive Oyl
Council whatever it is
delegate whatever they want to delegate
mm-hmm what happened to article 1 which
said the legislative power is in the
president or no sorry
is in the Congress it's just a small you
say now does that sound like a familiar
question of course it does
because it's the question that the New
Deal court faced what are these agencies
where does it say anything about the
International the ICC where does it say
anything about an agency in the
Constitution and then in in in famous
cases they gradually solve the problem
are we going to be in a similar kind of
situation but not visa vie the local not
the Interstate Commerce Commission but
rather for visa vie all kinds of
organizations that make up at 7 or 800
or 900 or a thousand different
institutions that we now belong to that
make rules than in practice make
practice bind us
maybe I mean they certainly had the
problem in Europe they've had the
problem in Europe in three three courts
Supreme Court of Germany of Austria of
Italy at least has had to look through
the EU treaties and say does our
Constitution in fact delegate to that EU
does it give them the government our
government the power to make a treaty
that gives all this power to the
European Union hmm all three have said
no they've said there are certain things
that are reserved they've never actually
found one but that you say that in
principle there's certain things
reserved we haven't had that kind of
question yet really I don't think unless
you go back to the agencies or something
like that I think it'll come up I can't
predict the futures as Yogi Berra but
nonetheless maybe good chance and as I
say we've nibbled around the edges
because there have been cases that sorta
brought up something somewhat similar
all right all I am trying to do is to
give you a taste a report a report of
whether you're talking about treaties or
you're talking about human rights like
Dolly filartiga or whether you're
talking about Commerce vast numbers or
whether you're talking even about things
were there a few cases but very
important ones security versus of the
civil liberties but the world that were
in is a world where you must look beyond
your own Shores and how and when and
under what circumstances is of course
going to be what the lawyers and the law
professors and the judges are busy doing
more and more and more and more and
that's all this book is about now but it
does have some reasons as to why I think
that's fairly important the the least
important reason perhaps is that there
are a lot of people who think you should
never cite foreign cases I mean that's a
reason I don't agree with that
I bet but nonetheless there are a few
and I want to say to those people look
if you're really talking about not
looking at what goes on elsewhere are
you serious I mean III pride or I've
tried you know different kinds of
arguments in different kinds of forums
and somebody will feel that very
strongly and I'll think I make a great
argument I was one of the Congress in
those [ __ ] I sent him a copy of this
book but but he said well he said I said
we said he had a big so he was very much
against the referring too far in cases
so I said probably that's aimed at me
and he said yes actually it is aimed at
you so I said well let me tell you why
we do that it's more and more countries
have constitutions like ours and they
have shown judges who are enforcing the
documents they have problems like ours
so if I see a person who has a problem
like mine and he has a judge like as a
job like mine and he has a document like
mine why don't I read what he says I
don't have to doesn't bind me but maybe
I'll learn something I thought that was
a great argument and he said fine read
it he said just don't refer to it in
your opinion so then not knowing when to
quit I said I said well anyway there are
a lot of countries where this is a new
thing and this new thing is there courts
want to go to their legislators and say
you know it's important that you pay
attention to judges here the Supreme
Court of the United States we cite them
all the time they refer to us that gives
them a little sometimes a little added
prestige what's wrong with that that
sort of a defense of of trying to get
them in a position where they find it
easier to defend civil liberties or who
defend personal rights of some kind say
he said fine he said send them a letter
so really what I want to say to him is
just read this okay that you read it and
now you tell me how we're gonna solve
these problems unless unless in fact we
can know what is happening in other
countries sometimes we have to follow it
sometimes we don't but not knowing about
it is in more and more and more and more
cases because what you're really
concerned about is of course preserving
basic American
values alright I agree with you I agree
with you that is important but when you
read this I think you'll think that
maybe the best way to do that given the
nature of the problems that are in front
of us the best way to do that is to know
what's going on elsewhere and to help
because after all if we don't help if we
don't help the world will go on without
us I mean we'll be affected by what
people do anyway and so whether it's
ball or whether it's the Whale
Commission or whether it's some other
thing maybe we ought to find out so that
it won't go on without us and that we
will make contributions to problems like
the environment or security or health or
commerce which are all around us as
you've just read in 200 well-chosen
pages alright but but did you see the
point I'm trying to make there and I'm
saying if you go really deep and I think
this drives us in all of us to some
degree I mean the thing that explains
our predicament in a sense and when you
start talking about American values I
think it was Lincoln it's corny but true
I mean he said he says there in
Gettysburg yeah you know we have to
memorize this we used to have do I've
forgotten most of it but he says four
score and seven years ago
but why four score and seven you say
that does not bring us back to the
Constitution it brings us back to the
Declaration of Independence he doesn't
want the Constitution he wants the
Declaration of Independence because it
says all men are created equal and of
course the Constitution doesn't so four
score and seven years ago our fathers
came forth upon this continent created a
new nation conceived in Liberty and
dedicated to the proposition that all
men are created equal we are now engaged
in a great conflict war to see if this
nation or any nation so conceived and so
dedicated can long endure and I said
that's the point I want the school
children to memorize because when they
created and you don't think about that
too often but when they wrote this
document in the 1780s
1790s there was no other place like this
there were all kings you know I mean
there wasn't and it was an experiment
and people were sitting around writing
that it won't work
as I said maybe it won't they don't know
if it will work or not they actually
have a document here that protects basic
liberties it depends upon democracy that
might be good on paper it'll never work
and they thought well this experiment
might work and now Lincoln is there why
did he ever say I would fight this war
which he did say I will fight I would
fight this war too even if no slave were
free I really slept maybe didn't believe
that but maybe he did I would fight the
war to free half and not the other half
I would fight the war to free all but
what he's thinking with those words is
he's thinking why fight this war because
if the country falls apart and it's
divided the experiment didn't work it
just didn't work it fell apart and
that's the part that I want to
communicate is that part because we're
still in it I mean it's corny to say
this but my goodness it's true we're
still in the experiment will the
experiment work or will it not work and
I think today that experiment means for
all of us who were lawyers or judges it
it means that great problems whether its
environment Commerce human liberty
treaties whatever they are they're
global in exactly the sense I've just
described and now once you accept that
you say either we show that you can
somewhat deal with these problems at
least help a little bit through
cooperative efforts which means trying
to have rules which we call laws or
rules or rules of law you say yeah
that's one way to do it and if we can't
show people that you can do it that way
they'll choose other ways and the other
ways are pretty horrible when you turn
on that television set and see what goes
on in the world so maybe it's just a
description of what's going on
but really there is a program in I am I
thinking hard though that may be to see
sometimes but the program is simply to
show people the tremendous importance of
learning these details of seeing what's
going on of trying to work out through a
way in their many ways of trying to
reach beyond our own Shores so that we
can show that a rule of law that is a
rule of law that does protect human
rights that does protect democracy can
contribute something to these world
problems and that's called supporting
the rule of law itself so there you have
it we have where I started what the book
is about and why I wrote it thank you
when you signed up everyone was given an
opportunity to ask questions we have a
few questions we have time for a few for
the justice and I'll just read a couple
some your honor so that you can respond
this is from an alumnus of the Society
Supreme Court summer institute for high
school teachers program and he or she
writes my foreign policy class is
conducting a simulation of a National
Security Council debate over the use of
enhanced interrogation techniques
against suspected terrorists how do you
recommend we prepare for such a debate
what legal principles are essential for
my students to understand in this
complex issue oh they'll know more I
mean how to prepare for it there are
studies and documents I'll have to read
them and see what the facts are that's a
good point for lawyer isn't it start
with the facts and oddly enough
sometimes the facts aren't quite what
you think and sometimes they're worse
sometimes they're better and then I I
think reading I I would read Jackson's
opinion in steel seizure I think that's
a very interesting opinion because you
get that and start asking questions
about that opinion you'll say why is he
hesitant and they'll be an answer and
why does he think that Harry Truman went
too far why when all of his advisors
told him you've got to do this or it'll
be terrible
and what rule would you in fact have and
what does Europe's experience in World
War two and just before tell us and etc
etc in other words I think something she
might not otherwise think of is that
opinion and a steel seizure case so I'd
look at that I'd look at that you can
look at Guantanamo 2 but it isn't going
to give you an answer it might start you
in the direction the answer you could
have a good debate in the class what do
these four cases what does boo median
tell us about the proper answer to this
case and I'd read C depends on how far
she goes in the torture direction
because you can go short of that and get
you
more interesting you know get a debate
going around Barack wrote a very good
opinion about the use of some form of
torture in Israel he was Chief Justice
of Israel and he writes in there which
is so interesting to me and it was not
it wasn't some terrible you know it was
not great but it was a form of torture
and he says now do you think I don't
understand do you think I don't
understand the fact that there can be
somebody who knows where they're going
to blow up the cafe and indeed what he's
trying to do by saying go and tell my
mother I'm fine you say go put the bomb
underneath the chair and said it all
because do you think I don't understand
that he says I do understand it I do
understand it very well and I understand
why you think there is a need but he
says of course this appeals to me he
says we are judges and you cannot ask a
judge to approve torture and that's the
opinion read that read read Jackson and
then maybe you know have a few examples
but where the other way okay that's my
best the second question is in an
increasingly globalized legal world the
Supreme Court's decisions serve as a
guide sometimes explicitly through
citation and quotation for foreign
courts around the world in what
circumstances does the Justice consider
the courts global audience when crafting
his or her decisions further what are
the justices thoughts on foreign courts
increasingly citing u.s. circuit and
state courts is this trend concerning
given conservative instincts
conservatives increased focus on gaining
seats in state judiciary's no no it's
not a concern people can so excite what
they want I mean you know but then sight
what they want an honest opinion is an
opinion that that tells the real reason
why the judge is deciding this way and
we cite Law Review articles we
briefs we cite all kinds of things so
III don't see anything wrong with citing
whatever people want to cite as far as
an audience is concerned for our
opinions abroad no I'm not I mean that's
their problem that's not my problem
my problem is to get this thing done
correctly but in doing this thing
correctly it may turn out such as the
examples that I've given you where it's
very helpful to know what other people
have done and so if other people find
but we get done is helpful to them
that's fine but that's their problem not
our problem my problem is to get this
opinion written correctly that's hard
enough before I take on a few of us
alright one last question if someone
were going to make a summer study of
important non-american legal texts to
better understand the global judiciary
do you have any that you would recommend
for their review I would read Brock
sings he's written on this and and I
would try to read something about what
the German Constitutional Court has done
it's pretty interesting they've had
they've had quite quite quite a few
cases in this that that's changing
rapidly I'd look up what kassay see
professor Chris AC has written on this
subject that's pretty interesting and
that's what comes to mind at the moment
thank you very much
Your Honor I want to want to thank you
in particular ladies and gentlemen this
is the most demanding time of the year
for the court as they come closest to
the end of term and to devote this time
is something that we really do owe I
think a standing ovation for for this
[Music]
I want to thank everyone who has come
here today for those of you that are
taking the tour at 3 o'clock you meet
right outside there I do want to mention
that the book shop is open and if you're
thinking of graduation gifts there's one
in mind that is signed downstairs for
those of you that are going to join us
at the annual meeting of the trustees
and the society it's at 6:30 tonight in
this room and for those of you with
reservations the reception will begin at
7:00 and the dinner at 8:00 thank you
all very much I look forward to seeing
you this evening
[Applause]
you're watching American history TV all
weekend every weekend on c-span 3 to
join the conversation like us on
facebook at c-span history
this